cela peut paraître étonnant mais voici
des vertèbres lombaires imprimé en 3d
ces prototypes anatomiques ont été créés
par le groupement des intellectuels
aveugles ou amblyopes ils ont pour
objectif de soutenir la formation des
étudiants masse au kinésithérapeute
malvoyants à la différence du
clairvoyant qui lui a la possibilité de
voir d'entrée de jeu dans son ensemble
pièces anatomiques le déficient visuel
n'a pas cette capacité donc il est
nécessaire pour lui de pouvoir la palper
l'étudier avec le grâce au toucher et de
pouvoir ensuite on l'a des montants
apprécier l'ensemble de lance du contenu
d'une articulation en france 2000
praticiens masse au kinésithérapeute un
handicap visuel pour pouvoir développer
son projet le gia s'est associé à la
fondation dassault systèmes a aussi reçu
se reprocher ça m'a semblé évident parce
que finalement l'impression 3d qui
s'appuie sur les mondes virtuels
l'impression 3d permet de créer des
outils qui vont complètement
révolutionné la manière dont ces
étudiants qui ont des problèmes de vue
qui sont déficients visuels vont pouvoir
apprendre de nouvelles pièces 3d seront
créés bientôt principalement des
articulations
ces outils pédagogiques seront
disponibles auprès du gia avant la fin
de l'année et seront accompagnées aussi
d'un support audio et de commentaires en
alphabet braille